hi in this video we are going to talk
about hemoglobin and it's oxygen binding
kinetics so we know that hemoglobin is a
key molecule or the key oxygen
transporter molecules situated in our
red blood cells now hemoglobin is a
large protein with at least four
subunits and each of these subunits are
composed of him multi which is an on
protein structure it's a protocol firing
ring but along with it it has the globin
protein and each of these sub unit
weighs around of 65 cubes in all the way
now he is human
so there is the protein part and there
is a huge part now him part is the
particular moiety which binds to the
oxygen so when we talk about hemoglobin
and it is binding with the oxygen we
have to understand how oxygen is binding
to the face in making goo-goo in inhale
moiety so the human consists of global
Logan is a protein so blogging is
encoded by alpha and beta globin genes
located in chromosome number 16 and
chromosome number 11
so then we need to understand where does
the heel come from and how the Himba
synthesis takes place so he mustn't this
is takes place from intermediate of
Krebs cycle
sucks in air iike way now the succeeding
way and then University glycine is
together used to form the other amino
Lunik acid which gets eventually
converted to him right now
this heel can bind to the oxygen but the
he move in the moving chain for the
hemoglobin might be very different for
different type of hemoglobin and it
turns out that there are several
different types of hemoglobin present in
human body but their abundance
r2p you for example hpa2 or HBS their
abundance is pretty low
HB a one which is composed of
two or four residues andto bitter
residues to alpha blooming residues and
to be the glowing residues are having
the highest abundance in case of fatal
situation the hemoglobin is different
it's known as embryonic or fetal
hemoglobin or HB 8 in that case the
subunits are alpha subunits and the
epsilon sub units and fetal hemoglobin
has totally different affinity towards
oxygen I doubt so that would be topic of
another video but in this video I will
talk about is a structure and function
of these blooming is pretty much concern
throughout several species of the animal
kingdom
so it's evolutionary conserved so we
obtain oxygen from the environment so
when we breathe oxygen comes in our
lungs and inside our alveoli which are
the air-filled sex it is surrounded with
blood vessels so in the blood vessels
there is exchange of oxygen and carbon
dioxide but oxygen cannot dissolve
properly in the blood because it's
solubility is very low so it binds to
the oxygen carrier protein which is the
hemoglobin and in this video we'll learn
about the binding kinetics so let's look
at the structure from a side view so
here is a side view of the profiling
ring in a movie so you can see the ring
is pretty much in a non planar wedge
shape when that oxygen is not bound but
when oxygen binds the conformation of
the ring changes ring becomes planner in
oxygen bound state and you can see the
nearby histidine residues are bound to
these oxygen with several non covalent
interactions and this conformational
change would increase the probability of
the nearby site for oxygen binding and
this kind of binding method is known as
copper TV cooperativity and this is an
example of a which is the oxygenated
right now now these subunits are bound
to oxygen in this situation and so our
veins look purple or
now baby binds to one molecule of oxygen
and more mental bound binds to the group
and that increased the probability of
binding in the next subunit so in this
fashion in a progressive and sequential
fashion the binding is facilitated by
the binding of the oxygen in the first
subunit and this kind of binding method
is known as cooperative binding but how
do we understand this binding in a
mathematical format you need to
understand that we have to understand
Hill equation which is a mathematical
format we allow us to understand the
binding kinetics so let's look at it
imagine we have a protein which we are
saying P and it's a multi-subunit
protein so you can bind with several
ligands in this case the ligands are
known as L and there are n number of
ligands so you can create a protein
Linnaean complex like this and we are
saying the association constant so this
equilibrium constant is K a so we can
define K a and the derive we can derive
the expression for K a and the case
expression pretty much look like this
then what we can do can express the
equation in terms of a binding fraction
or saturation fraction saturation
fraction simply means binding sites
occupied divided by total number of
binding sites so this pretty much looks
like this particular mathematic equation
PL n divided by P now substituting the
value of p ln which we derived from the
k association constants expression we
can get an expression like this and
little juggling around the terms and
taking comb we can derive that theta or
the binding fraction is ln l 3 / 10
divided by m to the power n plus 1 by K
8 1 by k 8 on is actually the
dissociation constant because
dissociation constant is just opposite
of the association constant so we can
modify the phrase and write it like this
now if we do the math a little bit more
and take in both sides before taking law
we need to be
so theta by 1 minus theta looks like
Ilyn divided by KD so now we take a look
in both the sides and we end up with
this kind of expression and this
expression is basically the field
equation and the end is here the hint
waifish it in a graph it would look like
something around something look like
this so here in the y-axis you have log
theta by 1 minus theta which is also
known as binding fraction or saturation
saturation and the median concentration
is given so you can think if we talk
about hemoglobin so it would be partial
pressure in case of the concentration
the current looks like this so it will
do or concentrate lower affinity state
the N or D coefficient is 1 but the he
coefficient is high for the higher
affinity state oops here anyway so let's
move on to the next curve to understand
how the partial pressure of oxygen
changes and how that affects the binding
of oxygen to a moving so here this log
theta by 1 minus theta term we can write
it by percent saturation of and the
local term we can write as like a
partial pressure of oxygen in this
alternator now let's look at this
portion of the graph so here that claw
curve has flattened and it's pretty much
reached a platter in this situation if
we increase the partial pressure of
oxygen we can see the y-axis there is
not much change in the percent
saturation but look at the ascending
phase of the curve in that ascending
phase if we change the partial pressure
of oxygen even a little bit like this
much then there is a huge change in the
percent saturation that means the
binding kinetics changes even you change
a liminal amount of the partial pressure
of the oxygen so this particular
ascending fail in this particular
ascending phrase the changing partial
pressure of oxygen can change the oxygen
binding kinetics
where
higher concentration or higher
saturation fraction changing partial
pressure does not make any sense let us
understand how so at the ascending phase
we can see the phenomenon of
cooperativity so each of these oxygen
molecule binding to one subunit would
allow the other subunit more likely to
bind to the oxygen and this cooperative
nation of binding allows the increase in
our sin saturation in the small increase
of partial pressure of oxygen but at a
very high level of saturation all the
sites which can bind to oxygen are
occupied so if you change the pressure
and pressure of oxygen they are not even
enough sites where oxygen can bind and
that is how we need to understand oxygen
dissociation curve so this is the pretty
much initial video about the oxygen
dissociation curve where we touched upon
the hill coefficient and rewrite it but
there are several physiological factors
such as - concentration concentration pH
intermediate such as - 3 BPG can shift
this curve either towards right or
towards the left and each of that has a
particular physiological and clinical
significance about that in a different
video so stay tuned came back next video
I hope this video was useful if this
video was useful give a big thumbs up
don't forget to Like share and subscribe
just to let you know that I am also
present in our Academy you can have a
one on one session email me with me and
we - you have to join the plus
subscription which is fully cheap and
you can use my code KP 10 to get a 10%
discount so stay home guys and stay safe
thank you